So I want to look at
HMMs in the context of
what's referred to as
Gesture Recognition.
It's sort of an old approach, an old
problem, especially using HMMs but it's,
it's, it's a good paradigm.
There's a conference called Face and
Gesture, in, Computer Vision.
So, obviously gesture must be important
because there's a whole conference
called Face and Gesture.
And it's a long story going back to
college of mine about why face and
gesture are put together.
I'll tell it to you some other
time over drinks of some flavor.
[COUGH] the typical scenario was you
do some examples of each gesture.
The system learns or is trained to
have some sort of model for each.
And like said lots of things used HMMs.
And at run time one would compare the
output of each of the different model,
you would evaluate what you saw in
terms of the likelihood sequence.
And if that probability
exceeded some threshold,
you'd say, uh-huh,
a particular gesture happened.
So this was done, as I said awhile ago,
sort of the mid-90s,
then it started to taper off.
Because partially this whole
idea of having sort of
individual trained gestures that people
would do to, to make something happen,
that didn't feel like just the
recognition of individual vocabularies.
So it's sort of tapered off.
But then all of a sudden, new life was
injected into the field of gesture
recognition and it was because
of human robotics interaction.
Okay?
People really love the idea of
being able to gesture to a robot.
Which if you've ever been to my lab we
sometimes gesture to the robot in a not
so friendly way.
But this idea that you
could do things and
control a robot, first of all,
speech is very difficult
in a noisy environment unless
you're wearing a microphone.
Gesture, you might be able to
do something more remotely.
And it was just this general
idea that it was kind of cool,
to be able to make some gestures and
have a robot respond appropriately.
So and here I just pulled out a paper,
Reed 2014.
This was at some conference
that just happened, and
since I'm recording this in 2014, it's
a, you know, I'm not making this up.
This is, you know,
what's currently going on.
I'm not advocating one way or
the other the importance or
whatever of this
particular piece of work.